Kanye says what what should be obvious
by now is that I was raised to stand for
my truth regardless of the consequences
so I will say this again I was mentally
misdiagnosed and nearly drugged out of
my mind to make me a manageable
well-behaved celebrity here's a text he
posted from someone named Harley that
says I'm going to help you one of a
couple ways first you and I sit down and
have a have an loving and open
conversation but you don't use cuss
words and everything that is discussed
is based in fact and not some crazy
stuff that dumb friend of yours told you
or you saw in a tweet second option I
have you institutionalized again where
they medicate the crap out of you and
you go back to Zombieland forever play
date with the kids just won't be the
same wow that's evil I just it's that's
insane man that's scary stuff it's also
blackmail I think I don't know who this
person is what kind of power they have
well I don't even know if the Texas
doctor to be honest but I don't think
Kanye would lie but I don't know